yiyu grew up alongside his older sister
tsutaku tomioka when he was still a
child his sister sacrificed herself to
protect him from the demons after the
death of tsutaku yuyu tried to tell
others that a demon had killed her
however he was labeled as mentally ill
and was sent away to one of his
relatives a doctor giyu ran away during
the journey there and almost died on a
mountain but he was rescued and became
apprenticed under sekonji urukudaki yiu
was 13 years old when he met sabito
while training under sukhonji and they
became good friends due to their similar
pasts and age together they entered the
final selection on mount fuji kasani
unfortunately giu was injured after a
demon's attack and was saved by sabato
who defeated nearly every demon on the
mountain however after the week went by
it was revealed to gilu that sabito was
the only one who died during their
selection as a result of this giyu
started developing doubt about the
authenticity of his position after
becoming the water hashira
final selection arc while tanjuro was
struggling to fend off the attack from
his demon-turned sister nezuko do you
attack the latter from behind only to
fail as tantro moved neziko out of the
way recovering quickly the swordsman
asked the boy why he protected the demon
he replies that the demon is his sister
looking at the madden nezuko giu
questions this statement before swiftly
removing the girl from her brother's
grip tangero prostrates himself before
the swordsman begging for his sister's
life giug grows angry at his actions
stating that he has no authority over
who lives or dies he continues by saying
that tundra is too weak to protect his
family all of his talk about finding a
cure for his sister's condition and
finding his family's killer is
ridiculous giuyu also states that he
could have skewered them both and be
done with it as the boy ponders these
words giu silently encourages him to
find the resolve necessary to accomplish
all of the lofty goals he had placed
upon himself he then stabs niziko in the
chest causing tantra to throw a stone at
him in fury giul blocks the stone with
the hilt of his sword avoiding another
of the projectiles as tanjro charges at
him seeing the attack attempt is only a
simple act of emotion the swordsman
angrily drives the hilt of his sword
into his attacker's back knocking him to
the ground staring down at the fallen
boy he who wonders where his opponent's
axe is looking up he sees the weapon
spinning towards him through the air
narrowly dodging it he then uses over
tonjero's clever strategy without
realizing that the boy was empty-handed
when he attacked distracted the
swordsman is attacked by nezuko dodging
backward from her kick cursing himself
gee watches as the girl reaches for her
brother confident that she will devour
him to his surprise she stands
protectively in front of his prone body
before charging at him again in rage yiu
sheaths his sword incapacitating the
unusual demon with a bare-handed blow to
the neck while tantro and nezuko are
unconscious giu wraps the demon in a
clean cloth and straps a bamboo
muzzle-like tube across the girl's mouth
when tantro regains consciousness the
swordsman instructs him to visit sukonji
urukodaki and not take his sister out in
the sun before promptly leaving he would
later send a letter to sukhonji
requesting for him to train tantro and
explaining the boy and his sister's
circumstances this video is brought to
you by manscaped.com the premium global
brand for men's grooming and hygiene
products manscape sent me their
performance package 4.0 which is an
all-in-one men's grooming kit for body
hair removal from head to toe let's
check it out i have to say this trimmer
being waterproof and cordless comes in
clutch especially because i can do all
my trimming in the shower without the
messy cleanup this saves me time too it
also has ceramic blades with skin safe
technology which really helps reduce
nicks and cuts and the blades can be
easily replaced so you can groom your
body with confidence head over to
manscapes.com and get 20 off plus free
shipping and two free gifts when you use
my promo code jaegerists at
manscaped.com
mount natogumo arc after receiving news
of the mini mizunoto ranks and demon
slayers perishing on mount nato gomo
kagayak orders giyu and chenobu to
assist the lower ranked swordsman upon
arriving guillus saves enosuke from the
father spider demon by cutting off its
arm and easily beheading the demon with
water breathing inosuke is quickly
impressed with his strength and demands
a duel instead giul berates him for his
lack of awareness stating that the demon
wasn't one of the 12 kizuki and ties
inosuke up after he tries to argue guil
later intervenes in the battle between
tanjuro and lower rank 5 rui saving the
former from rui's blood demon art he
praises tonjiro for holding out so long
and that he would take care of the rest
rui attempts to use blood demon arc
cutting thread rotation on the hashira
giyu nullifies the attack with his water
breathing 11th form dead calm cutting
apart all the threads while rui is
shocked by how easily the technique cuts
through his threads yu swiftly beheads
him shinobu suddenly appears and tries
to attack nezuko giu deflects her attack
and she gracefully lands shinobu tells
him to move aside so she can kill nezuko
giyu asks if tonjiro can move and tells
him to run the boy does while
simultaneously thanking him and
apologizing after the two hashira are
alone shinobu warns guiu that he is
violating the demon slayer code of
conduct after the siblings escape yiyu
manages to hold shinobu under his arm
and prevent her from chasing after them
but a crow interrupts relaying to the
demon slayers that tanjro and nezuko
were to be brought into custody
rehabilitation training arc giu is later
seen aloof at the hashira meeting where
tonjiro and nezuko are put on trial
kagaya ubu yashiki presents himself and
the hashira bow down in respect then
nichika ubu yashiki is requested by her
father to read forma hashira sakonji
urukudaki's letter stating that tantro
soconji and giyu will all commit seppuko
if nezuko were to attack or eat a human
after hearing sukhonji's and giu's
sacrifice to keep his sibling alive
tangero breaks into tears hashira
training arc following the events at the
swordsmith village giu attends an
emergency meeting with the other hashira
and amman ubuyashiki where they discuss
demon slayer marks after amman reveals
the planned training for hashira that
have received the mark giyu decides to
take his leave much to the annoyance of
sonemi and obanai when shinobu requests
that he at least explain giu states that
he is different from the other hashira
and exits after tonjiro finishes healing
he receives a letter from kagaya he is
requested to talk one on one with giu
and convince him to work alongside the
other hashira the boy visits giyu and
talks to him about the training much to
the latter's exasperation after asking
why he was mad giu tells tangero that he
should have stuck to water breathing and
become the water hashira as he was not
worthy of holding the position tangero
hammers him with questions asking him
what his words meant eventually wearing
him down and finally making him admit
that he technically never passed the
final selection giu reveals that he was
in the same selection as sabito whom he
met and befriended while under the
instruction of sekonji he describes how
sabato had saved him early on and went
on to defeat nearly every demon on the
mountain before his unfortunate death in
contrast giu had not defeated a single
demon yet passed this fact built the
inferiority complex that made him feel
unsuitable for a position as a hashira
persuading him that sabato would have
likely received the mark rather than
himself after hearing his story tonjiro
relates giu's experiences to his
experiences with rengoku they survived
at the expense of the stronger person's
death in both cases thinking about this
tandro asked gu if sabito's expectations
for giu to live a fulfilled life were
what held them together these words
shocked the hashira reminding him of an
interaction with sabito where the latter
convinces him to not die for the life
his sister gave him giyu thinks of his
deceased friend and sister apologizing
to them for his stubbornness and tells
tangero he would train after completing
gilmae's training tandro makes his way
over to giyu's house and witnesses an
intense spar between giu and tsunemi as
the two continue using their respective
breathing styles to fight their wooden
swords break and sonami eagerly proposes
fist fighting chandro intercepts them
asking sundami to calm down and offers
to eat a hoagie together after figuring
out senemy enjoyed the food out of anger
sunami knocks tandro out and storms off
chandra wakes up a few moments later and
giu explains to him that he and tsunemi
were just training not fighting asashira
also attended each other's training
sessions after this clarification giu
and tundra think of ideas to befriend
sanemi infinity castle arc following
kagaya's death giu is seen with the
other hashira attacking muzan kibutsuji
he eventually enters nakeem's infinity
castle alongside tonjiro the two are
soon ambushed by akasa tantro begins
engaging akasa in a fight who lunges
forward to attack first forcefully
pandro is narrowly able to escape the
blow using hinukamikakura firewheel to
flip over akasa after witnessing their
small scuffle giulio stands amazed at
tanzaro's techniques thinking of how his
ability is equal to that of a hashira he
recalls the snowy day when they first
met and how all he could do was beg for
his sister's life compared to how he can
now fight without losing his life or
dignity giyu uses the water-breathing
flowing dance to maneuver around akasa
the latter recognizing him as the water
hashira and stating it has been 50 years
since he had faced a heshira that uses
the water breathing akasa responds by
using his destructive death forcing him
to defend himself tundra appears from
behind using hinukamikura to slash a
kaza's neck only for the blow to miss
and for the demon to appear behind him
instead about to punch through his neck
tundra nearly gets hit when giulio saves
him by slicing akaza's arm off using the
water breathing however akaza's arm
grows back almost instantly and giuli
quickly attacks again with tonjiro akaza
sees him trying to slice his foot and
use his leg type crown splitter knocking
the demon slayer tantro crouches down to
soak up the pain leading giulio to face
akaza alone akasa compliments his
opponent's sword and asks for his name
only to be denied i don't have a name to
tell a demon and i hate talking so don't
bother the demon happily responds he
loves talking and will continue asking
until he gives in akasa then uses
another technique to hit his blade
handle and knocks the heshira away
through several walls
soon giu returns angered at the searing
pain in his back and sarcastically
thanking the upper moon for blasting him
through the wall as gee and akaza face
each other giul comments on why he
fights he doesn't want to battle to his
best ability and he doesn't like battles
where opponents continually swing for
fun but before now he had never faced
someone who quickly overwhelmed him as
he finally understands the moments of
life and death in a battle that truly
tests one's abilities tundra watches as
yiu unlocks his demon slayer mark gew
rushes forward and swings the blade just
missing akasa's neck akaza tries to
punch his head off but the hashira ducks
down and swings again with the demon
bending back to escape the strike akaza
realizes the mark has appeared and his
speed has now increased giu uses his
water breathing fourth form striking
tide and slices through akaza's forearm
however the ladder had attacked and
struck the side of geyu's head seeing
akasa open from giu's blow tantro
attempts to use the hinukamikagura on
the upper moon's exposed neck but akaza
catches the blade without even seeing it
after that akasa begins to overwhelm
giyu the latter having used all his
water breathing forms only for akaza to
adapt to all of them immediately the
upper moon decides to finally kill him
commanding the heshira for lasting this
long in battle as tantro attempts to
enter the selfless state giu tries to
directly strike the demon's head akasa
responds by dodging the blow then using
the side of his fist to break giu's
nichiren sword as giu becomes stunned at
having his sword broken akaza farewells
him before crouching down preparing to
punch through his stomach suddenly
akash's hand falls off saving you from
getting hit tundra has managed to enter
the selfless state and bypass a kaza's
compass needle as gui looks on at
tundra's new appearance and power
akasa's body becomes stricken with
uncertainty at tanjuro's changed aura he
deploys his final form technique
deployment final form blue silver
chaotic afterglow geo looks at this new
threat and is uncertain if he can negate
it with his dead call technique gyu
cannot defend himself from akaza's new
technique and is knocked back against
the wall the demon commands him for
surviving such a large number of fatal
blows and tells him don't die like
kyogiro and tanjuro become a demon giyu
however the water hashira becomes
confused wondering how akaza can state
that he killed tanjiro with tantros
standing right behind him he realizes
maybe he can't sense his partner and
mutters to tantro to go for the neck now
that akaza is unaware instead tantro
calls out to the upper moon and declares
he will decapitate him annoying giu for
announcing his attack out loud i mean
this is ordinary anime stuff the attack
doesn't count if you don't shout right
before it everyone knows that
akasa attempts to swipe the demon
slayer's head only for tonjro to duck
down to safety akasa wonders how he is
able to avoid his final form but assures
himself that he is safe since his
compass needle will sense any incoming
attack suddenly he realizes he cannot
sense anything seeing tundra as entirely
different from before shocking him with
tangero's battle spirit seemingly gone
akasa tries to calm himself and believes
he will be able to sense an attack
however without warning his head is
sliced off by tandro using the
hinukamikagura setting sun
transformation with gius stunned at
chonjiro's feet akasa declares this
impossible unable to sense what happened
the upper rank tries to put his head
back on his neck with the resolve to
continue fighting however giu flings his
broken sword at his head knocking it
away from a kaza's grasp upon seeing
akasa's body not disintegrating giu and
tonjiro start to worry akasa's headless
body activates destructive death compass
needle again and immediately attempts to
hit tonjero's neck fairly missing and
knocking tanjro unconscious giu sees
akasa going for his unconscious comrade
and uses water breathing to stop him
though the cuts instantly heal giu then
declares that if akaza wants to kill
tanjuro he needs to kill him first
akaza sees his indomitable spirit one
that doesn't bend in the face of any
obstacle as giu reads to fight akasa
once more he realizes the severity of
the situation he has reached his limit
his senses are failing his body is numb
and his breathing is the only thing
keeping him up giul focuses on
protecting the unconscious tantro
resolving never to let friends or family
die on his watch again knowing tonjro
would do the same suddenly akaza stops
his regeneration he unlocks memories
from his past and recalls his father
wife and kaizo finally he decides that
he doesn't want to fight anymore and
gives up tundra and gil watch as his
body finally fades into ash akasugai
crow calls out in the aftermath of the
battle tantro and gui have managed to
defeat upper moon 3 but are now
unconscious after some time the duo
regains consciousness and attempts to
find other demon slayers
running through the hallway they are
shocked to see that muzan has appeared
right in front of them muzon begins to
speak to them saying that their
persistency is sickening him to the
bottom of his heart the demon lord says
that the demon slayers always talk about
avenging their families and friends
believing they should be thankful that
they had not died and simply continue
with their lives muzan suddenly attacks
demon slayers and they are barely able
to dodge the attack muzon unleashes an
even more powerful attack and giu barely
blocks with his dead calm technique
tundra is entirely unable to keep up
with the attacks and dodges them on pure
instinct but still attempts to close the
distance he manages to do so but before
he can attack muzon the demon slices him
and manages to cut into his eye giul
quickly comes and saves tangero warning
the boy not to get too close saying that
the sun does not penetrate the infinity
castle muzon asks if three hashira are
really enough to kill him the count
takes giu and tanjiro by surprise as
muzan continues and says that his
subordinate had already killed obanai
and mitsuri he had seen this through her
eyes to muzan's surprise he gets
ambushed by mitsuri and obanai who turn
out to be alive confused muzon wonders
how the two hashira he had seen dead
could still be alive he yells nakeem's
name asking what is going on yushiro
responds to him saying that he is now in
control of the infinity castle muzon's
attention is suddenly brought back to
the battlefield as giu and obani attack
him with their respective breathing
forms the demon lord soon realizes that
he won't be able to fight the heshira
and yushiro simultaneously hence he
clenches his fist destroying the keem's
skull prompting infinity castle to crush
leaving them in the streets after the
collapse the demon lord burst through a
pile of rubble sending it flying in all
directions enraged moves on taunts the
demon's layers and dares them to keep
him there until dawn
gilu obanai and mitsuri together engage
the demon lord in battle however they
are all hit as muzon unleashes another
flurry of attacks he commends them for
still being able to move while also
acknowledging that those with demon
slayer marks will not fall so easily as
the battle progresses giu gradually
becomes weaker due to the poison the
demon lord inflicted with his attacks
and his sword is taken away from him by
one of muzon's whips other hashira
intervene with sannemi grabbing his
sword and throwing it near the water
hashira yelling at him to focus or else
he will kill him giu gratefully grabs
the sword and attacks with the
waterproofing resolving not to back down
and keep fighting till the end muzon
admits that they are more resilient than
expected but is unconcerned it is only a
matter of time before his poison kills
them all long before dawn suddenly
tomeo's cat jumps onto the scene and
injects them with the antidote as obani
manages to awaken his demon slayer mark
and turn his sword red he slices off
muzon's arms as the demon pauses sunemi
yells at giu to prepare himself as he
swings his blade at guillos turning both
of their weapons bright red as well
however out of nowhere muzan performs
his special attack and knocks all demon
slayers unconscious after a long battle
between tonjero and muzon tonjero with
the help of open eye manages to pin
muzon against the wall resolving to keep
holding him until dawn tonjero attempts
to tighten his grip and make his sword
go bright red but is unable to do so
suddenly geo appears behind him and
grabs his blade to help keep muzon
pinned with both demon slayers holding
on to the blade with their combined
might it turns bright red and muzon
instantly coughs up blood as the sun
rises steadily the demon quickly
attempts to think of a way to avoid
disintegrating muzan attempts to cover
himself in a wall of flesh to block the
sunlight from hitting his skin and
transformed into a giant baby as the
flesh grows outward and begins to
swallow up tanjuro he throws his head
back to headbutt giu out of the way he
then gets swallowed into it alongside
his blade as the water hashira yells out
to him determined not to die musan
continues his resistance and begins to
dig underground to avoid the sun giu and
tsunemi work in tandem to attack the
demon and prevent him from escaping they
are joined by obanai who will unleash
his serpent breathing suddenly tundra
tightens his grip and attacks muzon from
the inside causing him to scream in
agony before disintegrating once and for
all
after the fight is over giu gets up and
tries to find tantro and sees the boy
kneeling still holding his blade the
kakushi tearfully informs guillo that
tanjro is no longer breathing and has no
pulse giu is greatly saddened tearing up
and kneeling in front of tanjuro he
grabs the boy's hand and apologizes for
failing to protect him saying he was
always the one who ended up receiving
protection as everyone is crying over
tonjero's death they are all left in
shock as tantro opens his eyes revealing
that he survived and is now a demon to
everyone's shock tundra regenerates his
left arm and attempts to attack the
kakushi next to him but you reacts
quickly and pushes him out of harm's way
tundra suddenly attempts to find shade
to stop burning but giulio intercepts
him by stabbing him from the side and
dragging him to the ground however
tanjuro stops burning and giul looks on
in shock as the boy takes advantage of
the shira's surprise to attack him view
narrowly dodges but his chin is grazed
tonjero follows up with another attack
intercepted by inosuki who yells at his
friend and asks him what he is doing giu
then watches as nezuku runs forward and
hugs her demonified brother she manages
to hold him long enough for canal to
inject him with tamayo's drug reverting
him to his human form gi you heaves a
sigh of relief and a kakushi holds him
to keep him stable
three months after the battle against
muzan kibutsuji the world is now free of
evil demons the survivors of the battle
resolved to continue living despite all
they lost kiraya begins the final
heshira meeting with the two remaining
hashira giyu and sanemi both in
attendance kiraya announces that the
demon slayer corps is disbanding the ubu
yashiki family expresses their gratitude
to the heshira and the other demon
slayers for their centuries of service
and bow before them with both hashira
protesting at this telling the ubu
yashiki that they were the ones who kept
the court together and that they don't
need any gratitude giu tells kiraya that
he was excellent at his job and that his
father and ancestors would be proud the
boy tears up at these words and thanks
to you for the compliment the two
hashira look at each other and smile
their long journey finally ended click
on this video where we explained the
entire story of muzan kibutsuji why are
you still here click it